[Music]
why is it so hard to love your neighbor
well I mean if you think in terms of
evolution and how we got here
tribes and tribal affiliation kept us
alive so you had your group and it was
your group against the world and there
was a threat at anytime you had no idea
where the threat was coming from and so
the way that the species survived the
way that we got here was people held to
each other stuck close to each other
because you never knew what threat was
hiding in those bushes you even think
about early brain development is there a
lion in the bush or not the brain
developed quite quickly this radar for
yes or no because if there is one I'm
gonna run this direction really fast and
so some of these impulses they served us
very well and got us to this point but
the way that development works is
something that may have gotten you to
this point may now be in the way I mean
anybody want to go back to puberty I
don't I don't have a problem with
puberty I'm quite grateful for puberty
I'm also grateful that I moved through
it without it it could have gotten here
and so one of the the keys to
understanding how we grow as humans and
how we spiritually grow is something
served us well for a while and now you
transcend it you move beyond it but
you've also included it it's not like
you ignore it or avoid it or deny it it
simply helped shape you into who you are
and so to this day for many people the
other the one who isn't like me
all of these primal instincts well up is
is this a threat and could this person
be possible obstacle to my thriving and
growth I don't know I have to do all
sorts of assessment my radars on full
when it comes to interacting with those
people but the powerful thing that's
happening now is more and more people
and the moments that when you often grow
the most are when you are engaged the
moments when you engage or that person
who is the other who is them and you
discover
you discover if you look far enough
inside them that you see yourself and to
me that's the real that's the real
challenge the real art the real
invitation is to look far enough into
this person with the trust at some point
I will see myself I will see my
struggles I will see my challenges I
will see a bit of my story in them
I actually think Jesus would be
mortified that a religion started in his
name I think he'd be lucky what I think
Jesus came to wake us up and remind us
of the shared humanity the the brother
and sister nests of all of us I don't
think he came to create another division
where people could say are you this or
not this I find Jesus more compelling
than ever I find his message of love
grace compassion courage a third way of
non-violence in the world care for those
who the system has not worked for them
love for the widow the orphan and the
immigrant among you I find his way I
find him more compelling than ever I
believe but I think the last thing he
came to do was start another religion
that would divide us even more so when
he says love your neighbor which was a
text from his tradition he's quoting
something there if you love your
neighbor your neighbor could be anybody
and suddenly you have bonds and
connection and solidarity with all sorts
of people that's always the moments of
greatest joy so I don't have really a
problem with the word Christian unless
it becomes this giant bulky things that
serves just to divide people all the
more when Jesus message was about
bringing us together
[Music]